did you know that two out of every three guys will
experience some form of male pattern baldness by
the time they're 35 yeah i did for me i was pretty
ball by the time i was 25 i wish keeps have been
around when i was younger because advancements in
science i meant that there are now treatments that
can combat the symptoms of hair loss and help you
keep the hair that you have it's too late for me
my hair's not coming back but you don't have to
be like me you could stop your hair loss early
thanks to keeps keeps off as generic versions
of the only two fda approved drugs for treating
hair loss so you might have tried them
before but never at a price this slow
that's right if you were thinking this is some
sort of medicine so it's going to be expensive
you can be more wrong keep starts at just 10 a
month how does it work well for one thing there's
no need to visit a doctor's office just schedule
a quick online consult and a little bit later
discreet package will arrive at your door and
you can use it in the privacy of your own home
so if you're noticing that you're losing your hair
that's one problem that's not going to fix itself
do something about it for a limited time just go
to keeps.com forward slash biographics or just
click the link in the description below to receive
50 of your first order and now today's video
today's ant hero protagonist was a physics
graduate at oxford and in later life became
a stand-up comedian best-selling
author and recording artist but
it's what he did in between those things
that made him a folk hero or rather
an anti-hero at the peak of his activities
in the 1970s and 1980s he was at the head
of a drug smuggling empire responsible for
importing the largest ever shipment of cannabis
to the uk but the reign of this anomalous drug
lord did not rely on firepower nor intimidation
it rested solely on his charisma his ability
to forge useful contacts is inventiveness
and industrial quantities of cheek this is the
story of howard marx better known as mr nice
dennis howard marx was born on the 13th of august
1945 in kenvik hills south wales his mother was a
school teacher and his father was a skipper
of merchant ships young howard would travel
frequently on his father's ships his earliest
memory is of him throwing the sailor's cat into
the sea the only occasion on which his father used
corporal punishment besides this incident howard
was a happy bright and studious child entering
grammar school at the age of 11 that same year he
developed his first scam by flicking a thermometer
he could increase his temperature reading he could
then simulate a rare condition undulate fever he
spent weeks in a hospital ward being fed medicines
and pampered by attractive nurses this is how he
first experienced sexual arousal and developed
an early taste for drugs the ruse could not go on
forever though and howard had to return to school
soon he developed the worst possible reputation
that of being a bit of a nerd as a reaction he
modeled his persona after elvis presley howard
was a good piano player and could hammer out
some of the king's most popular tunes to bolster
his popularity howard became friends with an older
bigger and meaner boy albert hancock albert
took him under his wing and introduced him to
the only nightlife that ken fig hill had to offer
the local pubs around the age of 15 howard became
a fixture of the scene spending his evenings
swinging beer puffing on cigarettes and singing
elvis presley hits for the other patrons when his
dad found out he was grounded for six months but
little else to do howard went back to studying
and nailed his school exams at the age of 16. he
could now access the advanced level certificates
the subjects he chose were physics chemistry
and maths by day that is in the evening he
was still pursuing an advanced diploma in
booze live music and sex but surprisingly he kept
getting good grades at school so much so that the
headmaster of the school convinced him to apply to
balliol college in oxford to study physics howard
showed up to the admittance interview completely
drunk on beer but somehow he still nailed it
when howard first moved to oxford in september
1964 he made an interesting discovery attending
lectures was not compulsory so with plenty of
spare time he dedicated himself to his favorite
activities networking and chasing girls the
time for exams came along and howard realized
he'd studied little to nothing not a problem
though with a daring of burglary he broke
into the offices of the examiners and stole
a copy of the test papers during his second
year his network of popularity expanded howard was
constantly surrounded by friends and adoring girls
former oxford mate john nicholson said that there
was instant sunshine wherever howard went one of
his then-girlfriends lynn barber claimed that he
seduced her with two simple words come here during
this period howard made a new friend in dennis
ervin a landmark acquaintance which introduced
the young welshman to indian food and cannabis it
was a revelation howard was hooked both on tikka
masala and on grass his room at ballior became the
backdrop of a constant party people came in and
out at all times of day and night dancing through
the wafting mist of reefer then willing to explore
new boundaries howard accepted an offer to try lsd
the results were far from exhilarating he plunged
into a period of suicidal miserable thoughts a
bad trip it culminated with an incident which
he shot at a passer-by with an air gun the gun
was not loaded but the intended target filed a
complaint with jon jones the dean of the college
the dean was rather forgiving issuing only a
reprimand to howard who would not touch lsd again
freed of bad chemical influence howard returned
to his dire to beer and weed during his final
year at oxford howard and two friends moved out
of college into a house in paradise square they
shared lodgings with a heroin addict known to
the local police it was only a matter of time
before paradise square was raided in a drug bust
the police found the butt of a joint and took
howard and his friends into custody once again the
sympathetic dean stepped in he talked the police
into releasing the boys and even convinced howard
to take his studies more seriously and he did
the party animal was able to morph back into a
nerd when needed and he passed his final exams but
if he wanted a degree he had to carry out several
lab experiments something he had little practice
with what he had practiced though was cheating he
obtained a set of experiment results from other
students and copied them into his lab report
it worked and howard marx emerged from oxford
with a second class honours degree in physics
the last intense period of studies and
cheating had somehow pushed marijuana
out of howard's existence he was going straight no
drugs little booze and a steady girlfriend named
ilse who he married in december 1967. the two
moved to notting hill in london and signed up to
a teacher training course howard however soon lost
interest in the course he had started drifting
back into his old ways hanging out with old oxford
friend graham plinston this was the pivotal moment
which set marks on the road to becoming mr nice
princeton was not only a consumer of hashish but
also a dealer howard became his associate helping
shift his merchandise to a vast network of friends
first while based in london then oxford and then
later in brighton shortly after this latest move
howard hit the big time when graham princeton
was busted in germany marx contacted graham's
old suppliers essentially inheriting his network
while he was in jail in this period howard left
behind the last remnants of respectable life
he broke his marriage with ilsa and returned
to london to expand his activities soon he was
controlling much of the cannabis and hashish
imports to london distributing them to local
dealers in southern england when princeton was
released and returned to britain he and howard
continued working together this time as partners
on an equal footing their main supply route
originated in pakistan a third partner muhammad
durrani had enrolled several diplomats who
smuggled the drugs via switzerland marx invested
his ill-gotten gains in throwing lavish parties
and showering acquaintances with gifts and favors
in exchange some of them helped with selling
dough at a street level others participated in
setting up legitimate businesses as fronts such
as the fashion boutique anna belinda's in oxford
in 1971 howard and graham were tired of working
with durrani and the pakistani diplomats who kept
80 of the profits as they looked for other
smuggling partners they considered jim mccann
volatile man from belfast who claimed to
be a member of the provisional ras the
irish republican army in a meeting in cork in the
republic of ireland mccann asked marx to organize
the transport of cars filled with weapons from
wales into ireland mccann would take the guns
replace them with dope and ship the cars back
to britain marx immediately refused to smuggle
any guns mccann was adamant that howard had to
ship something anything to ireland they settled
for pornographic films business kept on growing
so much so that marx and princeton attracted the
attention of the british secret services one of
their agents hamilton macmillan had been friends
with howard at oxford the two got in contact as
macmillan wished to exploit howard's network to
infiltrate the underworld marx established
business relationships with crime syndicates
inside and outside the uk including the
us-based brotherhood of eternal love
a.k.a the hippie mafia he had been supplying them
via an ingenious scheme if a british band was
about to tour the united states marx ensured that
their amplifiers and speakers were filled with
hashish if no tour was scheduled well no problem
the welsh smuggler would organize fake doors for
non-existent bans one of such consignments was
intercepted at jfk airport in new york this
attracted the attention of the drug enforcement
agency the dea and the agent that would become
howard's nemesis craig lovato but before lovato
could do anything his dutch counterparts beat him
to the punch marx had been arrested in amsterdam
while on a business trip interrogated by the dutch
authorities he spun a story so unbelievable that
it actually worked no mr dutch policeman i'm not
a vulgar dope dealer i'm an agent on a majesty's
service i've been hired by mi6 to infiltrate the
ira's drug smuggling ring or something to that
effect as a result the dutch promptly extradited
him to britain while on bail awaiting trial marx
was not idle organizing shipments of hashish from
the middle east into the u.s in new york the dope
was bought by a powerful mafia family the gambinos
this connection led to a very unpleasant
experience the gambinos had dispatched to
mafioso to collect cash from a deposit box in
amsterdam marx was to give him details on where
to find the money when the box turned out to be
empty the mafia man paid a visit to marx he gave
him a beating and then threatened to kill his
family unless he paid him 10 000 pounds in cash
a terrified marx phoned his dad dennis asking
him to bring a suitcase full of money which he
had hidden in his parents home when marx met the
thug again the man was apologetic his boss back
in the u.s had told him that marx was an okay
guy who didn't deserve that kind of treatment
to apologize the gambinos offered to help him
jump bail it was tempting but if howard simply
disappeared then his parents would lose the 40
000 pounds that they deposited as bail money
being the nice guy that he was marx just couldn't
allow that he had a better idea in september 1973
a customs officer showed up at howard's oxford
flat and took him away it later turned out that
customs had never sent anybody to collect marks
the police suspected a kidnapping who could have
abducted the drug dealer the mafia the r.a or
well maybe himself the customs man was in fact a
london friend of howards and the two had staged a
fake abduction technically he had not jumped bail
by the late 1970s marx had become
one of the most wanted men in britain
he adopted a variety of disguises assumed
names and fake passports he later claimed
to have 43 bogus identities including the now
iconic missed nice when he bought a passport
from a convicted murderer donald nice so what
was the secret of his success well according
to criminologist carlo maseli of montreal
university it was the nature of his organization
unlike south american cartels or the mafia
howard's operations were not run as a militaristic
outfit with a rigid structure codes of honor
and quasi-bureaucratic procedures howard relied
instead on an informal yet cohesive network of
contacts and friendships which operated smoothly
thanks to a culture of mutual favors
and shared profit such an organization
did not require the use of violence to operate
therefore it didn't attract excessive scrutiny
from police forces thanks to his network and
chameleon-like skills marx was able to slip in
and out of britain undisturbed shifting tons of
cannabis across continents at a later stage de
agent lovato estimated that between 1975 and 1978
marx had shipped to the us 24 loads of marijuana
and hashish for a total of 25 tons of dope these
operations had involved the mafia the yakuza the
brotherhood of eternal love the thai army the
palestine liberation organization the pakistani
armed forces nepalese monks and other individuals
from all walks of life the total profit made by
all concerned was 48 million dollars but clearly
this wasn't enough for mr nice in 1979 marx
received 50 tons of cannabis from the trophicantis
a mafia family based in florida he delivered it to
the scottish coast via a fleet of tugboats yachts
and dinghies unfortunately for him the market was
too well supplied and it took too long to shift
the grass the trafficantes got restless if barks
couldn't sell the dope fast enough they would
take matters into their own hands a group of them
reached the uk but they weren't very discreet the
customs office put them under surveillance until
they saw them meeting a tall man who looked a
lot like marx the police launched a series of
raids leading to the arrest of howard and six
associates more importantly they confiscated
the largest consignment of cannabis ever imported
to the uk worth over 20 million pounds that's 76
million pounds today or around 103 million dollars
howard couldn't be proud when he saw the headlines
but he was due for jail as he awaited trial in
1980 he took the occasion to marry his latest
sweetheart judy lane their daughter amber age
2 was the bridesmaid they went on to have two
more children francesca in 1981 and patrick
in 1987. in november 1981 howard went on trial
his defense attorneys performed a miracle they
claimed that at the time of the tripacante deal
marx had an ironclad alibi he was in mexico your
honor an undercover assignment to combat terrorism
and the trafficking of hard drugs the defense
even produced passports and hotel bills to
substantiate their claim an unidentified mexican
secret agent showed up to testify in favor
of senior marx all of this was fabricated of
course but it totally did the trick the trial
judge remarked i hope the jury are following all
of this because i am a little lost the jury was
indeed following many of its members spellbound
by the charismatic personality of mr knight one
of them was seen doodling a heart unsurprisingly
the jury declared the defendant not guilty
marx was released in 1982 with all
intentions of going straight but in 1983
it was offered the chance to sell
250 kilograms of cannabis he accepted
and he was back in business he established ties
with a provider on the afghani pakistani border
and the two supplied tons of dope to the u.s
entering the market by plane or boat all the
profits were laundered in travel agencies paper
mills or deposited in safe accounts in hong kong
in that period howard judy and the kids relocated
to palmer de molauka the balearic islands in spain
locals and other expats howard was a loving father
and husband adored by his children they could not
suspect that mr nice was running a perfectly oiled
drug smuggling machine spanning five continents
but mr nice did not suspect that a dea agent
he had never met had been shadowing his every
move for years waiting for the right moment to
pounce thanks to british and dutch investigators
craig lovato had learned that one jim hobbs
acted as marx's phone operator from amsterdam
hobbs picked up phone calls from associates
all over the world and then connected them
to marx's home in palmer lovato received authority
to wiretap the lines and listen patiently
for months howard and his accomplices were always
careful to speak in code for example champagne was
marijuana or mozambique stood for mexico and so
on these phone calls could not be used as evidence
nonetheless lovato was able to reconstruct
important nodes in how it marks his network
he learned that his brothers-in-law george and
patrick lane were essential cogs purchasing drugs
from major suppliers or laundering profits the
big surprise came when howard connected with an
eccentric british expat in the philippines anthony
patrick andrew carnes berkeley lord moynihan the
aristocrat had made a fortune managing brothels
in the philippines and was said to travel with a
grenade launcher in the trunk of his car marx and
moynihan hit it off and sought to make business
together mr nice asked the lord if he could help
him buy land in the philippines to establish his
own marijuana plantation in february of 1986
president of the philippines ferdinand marcos
was deposed after 21 years in office lovato knew
that lord moynihan enjoyed the protection of the
regime with marcos gone he bid his weakest dea
agents flew to manila and convinced moynihan
to cooperate in exchange for his own immunity his
job would be to wear a hidden microphone to record
incriminating conversations with marx moynihan
delivered and in july 1988 lovato and the spanish
police arrested howard with his wife judy now
mrs box was never part of the organization but
she had picked up some calls on behalf of howard
which was enough for an indictment as marx was
resisting extradition to the u.s lovato offered a
deal if he accepted to be tried in america the dea
would release judy howard accepted he went on
trial in florida in 1991. this time he did not
try any creative defense shenanigans when howard's
brother-in-law george announced he would testify
for the prosecution he agreed to plead guilty mr
nice was sentenced to 25 years to be served at the
terre haute penitentiary indiana there he acquired
a new nickname narco polo but he also gained
a reputation as a model prisoner popular with
wardens and convicts which he taught grammar and
philosophy eventually thanks to his good behavior
howard marks was released on parole in 1995
howard emerged from prison a new man with a new
career that of an all-round entertainer in the
span of five years he appeared on the debut album
by the super furry animals founded record label
bothered worked as a dj and launched a successful
one-man comedy show theaters were sold out as
audiences laughed at howard's anecdotes of his
lawless life he later collected his stories in the
best-selling autobiography mr nice adapted into a
film starring reese evans in the lead marx later
admitted to a short relapse into drug dealing in
the mid-1990s he had bought a large quantity of
ecstasy ready to hit the market of dance clubs but
he realized they'd been sold an adultered batch
of pills and refused to push them the experience
convinced him that synthetic drugs were too easy
to be tampered with they could not compete with
the wholesomeness of natural drugs that is when
he started campaigning for the legalization
of cannabis even standing for election in
four parliamentary constituencies he did not win
a seat but that did not deter him from campaigning
during the following decade in the early 2010s
marx was celebrated as a cult figure or folk hero
he continued to publish books even venturing
into crime fiction in the early 2010s
but in january of 2015 he announced some very sad
news to his admirers he had been diagnosed with
late-stage colorectal cancer in a bbc interview in
october 2015 he revealed he had tried a variety of
treatments with unintended consequences it took
about eight weeks supply of cannabis oil in one
hit along with everything from apricot seeds
to moths all the crazy crackpot anti-cancer
things that you can take i just took the lot
and got sectioned and put in the nut house for
two weeks but no treatments neither experimental
nor crackpot could help him at that stage howard
marx died on the 10th of april 2016. our format
certainly could not do justice the myriad of
capers that filled the picturesque life of today's
protagonist that is why i encourage you to read
his autobiography mr nice i've read it myself it's
very good there's a link in the description below
he left this world leaving a dilemma behind
did he deserve his folk hero status for
issuing violence sale of hard drugs and efforts
to legalize cannabis or was he just another drug
lord a criminal whose actions should be condemned
i'll leave you with howard's own reflections from
one of his last interviews pretty much every
drug would be safer to society if legalized and
controlled rather than left up to the criminal
fraternity of course one has to have the caveat
that if a drug is discovered or synthesized that
makes you want to kill people and rape people
then make it illegal obviously i haven't taken
every drug in the world but i've taken a lot and
i haven't come across one that makes
you like that except possibly alcohol
which is the only one that's legal so none of it
makes sense to me so i hope you enjoyed today's
video before you leave let me tell you about
a new channel that i'm doing called into the
shadows so maybe the world isn't dark enough for
you well good news it absolutely is and if you'd
like to know more about the horrible things
that humans have been doing to each other
since well time immemorial well please check out
that new channel into the shadows from land mines
to penal colonies to horrific diseases if it's
horrific we cover it check it out through the
link in the description below again it's called
into the shadows and thank you for watching